the Joe Rogan experience I was walking
out of the Octagon I forget who who owes
interview my favorite is this every once
in a while like there's a few people who
choose that song like Cynthia kabocha vo
well let's get shout out to the first
Marcus Davis yeah Marcus Degas he he did
the the first thing and then he went
into the jump around but some people
every once in a while I don't know maybe
if they picked a bad song or something
like out of nowhere out of nowhere one
time like lyoto machida came out to jump
around on a mic I texted Tina I was like
who the [ __ ] picked daddy's like I did
some of these cats though choose music
it was like yeah and I think the go-to
Jam if you [ __ ] pigs let me doesn't
like cuz I'll be like that was random
and I was like how how did that happen
it's funny it's funny when this is a
song that plays all the time it connects
you to one of your friends like as I'm
walking out of the Octagon about six
years where anywhere Dana was it could
be I could be he could be on this side
of world I'm sleeping long I'd get a
phone call and he'd just be a phone in
the air at a club you guys nailed that
song so hard there's like moments in
space-time that get nailed just like you
you you just hit something that
resonates with people I I still Danny's
quote Danny boy's quote of uh it's the
Louie Louie of the 90s it's Louie Louie
it's just there it's part of the bike
it's it's almost not mine anymore
it's think belongs to the universe it's
weird
every ballgame I go to any event I go to
it gets played and it's not even like a
big deal about it's like some place is a
big deal like you get these football
games college like Wisconsin's and stuff
where it's like part of a tradition but
I'm saying any event angels game or
dodge became
Yankees game a Laker game a football
game it's it pops up somewhere along the
line dude you're right up there with
Queen it's crazy
it's wild I mean as you talking about
salt like individual songs and the fur
their imprint on something it's bananas
it's it's it's something to like I can't
you can't almost invest your thought in
it because it can get like whoa it's it
that's it's really kind of a part of pop
culture it's ingrained on an emeritus an
American phenomenon and world why I mean
like worldwide I mean yeah where did you
can you go where they probably don't
never heard jump around it's weird
I mean it's - think about it on that
level is crazy
maybe like one of them places where
Trump's trying to buy maybe open
Greenland no no today I don't know they
they heard it they heard it
[Applause]